hey guys how's it going so I've been
getting a lot of requests to do an
updated video on what I think of my
iPhone 7 plus if you guys are new and
have no idea I ended up getting the
jet-black one I have a bunch of videos
where I talked about the issues and
everything that I had with actually
getting it but it's here it's in my
hands I also got a lot of really great
comments on the fake unboxing that I did
which was technically a better unboxing
than the actual unboxing once I got the
phone but that's a whole nother story so
really just to dive right in I want to
talk about some of the problems that
people have been having with it because
some of them are kind of crazy like the
whole his state and their I haven't seen
any Ben gates yet but that was
previously back in the day the whole Ben
gate situation there was also the buzz
gate people had tons of reports of their
phones hissing and buzzing and making
all kinds of crazy noises I did in fact
run into the hiss and buzz gate
combination while doing some phone calls
I really do not make many phone calls at
all so a few that I had been on that
were longer than half an hour my phone
started getting a little bit warm and it
started making like a lot of like weird
noises in my ear and I'm not sure if
those were kind of transferred over to
the people on the other end I have no
idea but for the most part it's been
working really well and something that
I'm pretty impressed with is the dual
camera situation we've got going on here
when you're taking a photo you don't
really realize when you're switching
between one camera to the other it's
just pretty seamless it just freakin
works the photos look pretty great I
sometimes forget that I have this 2x
zoom that I can use now I'm pretty used
to the old phone where you don't really
like to zoom too much because sometimes
things will get pixelated but with the
2x zoom it really does make a huge
difference when you actually do remember
to use it so I thought I'd look up to
see what problems other people are
having with their phones and this is
kind of interesting because it's not
really necessarily a problem but I have
run into a few issues where I try to hit
the home button like with a towel or
something when I'm cooking so if I'm
pushing this button without actually
touching it with my skin it does not
work
push the button oh my mom hi mommy
so if you haven't really tried the new
home button it is a very weird sensation
because this doesn't do anything this it
gives you the feedback that you're
actually pressing a button but you're
really not it's strange it's it's weird
iPhone 7 can produce a hissing sound you
know I'm not really sure how many people
have really run into this issue I think
sometimes people make more issues out of
something that's really not an issue but
hey I don't know it could be a huge
thing have you guys run into this I'm
not even sure if what was happening to
my phone would be considered to his
skate or something completely different
as I also have it encountered the iPhone
7 can lose service after you put it in
airplane mode they first launched the
iOS 10 update I know t-mobile users were
having a lot of issues they advise not
to update until the next update but I
think that's all pretty much well and
fixed at this point I've owned 7 camera
lenses scratch too easily well I don't
think mine has any scratches yet I've
probably dropped it a total of four
times in the past week two weeks when
did I even get this phone let's take a
peak a week ago
oh my goodness I've only had it for a
week so in a week I've dropped it four
times okay I do have a case on it I went
with the white silicon case before I had
the white faced phones you would always
have sort of this white outline and then
this screen would be black and it kind
of kind of bothered me but I'm pretty
happy about everything that's going on
here so a week with my phone this is
this is wild the remote on Apple's new
lightning air pods can sporadically stop
working so I haven't really used the
Apple earpods that much because they
don't really work for my ears I don't
know if I have a strange your type but
no matter what they just really do not
work what is happening then what is that
slip there's been a few times that I've
run into the past the ox' situation
where it gets a little bit awkward
because I forget that that aux cable
will no longer work with my iPhone
and it's kind of strange because it
really is I mean it's I don't like to
say it's like a lifestyle change but it
technically sort of is because the
headphones that you have before you no
longer can use and I finally just
traveled this past week to New York and
usually when I travel I have a very set
kind of strict schedule of how I pack
things and what I do and where things go
so the fact that I had this little
dongle where are you I don't even know
where it is I lost this dongle so many
times my friend ed and I had a really
great time of putting the dongle places
that it shouldn't be like underneath
your Starbucks cup so it looks like the
Starbucks cup that has a lightning cable
to aux dongle it you know it's a lot
funnier in person
I guess maybe I'll try to get you guys
at a little example so you know what I
mean
[Music]
I mean it's funny I promise it's yeah
one of the real issues that I sort of
ran into was the dongle not really
working in my car after I posted about
this somebody said it's because it's
also sending a current to charge your
phone and it might have got confused
that's why I was getting this weird
feedback but my car does not play audio
through my phone I can take calls and do
things like that but it doesn't play
music through bluetooth so really there
hasn't been too much that has been that
alarming for me it's always interesting
to hear the Android complaints I mean
I'm not a pose to Samsung or Android or
anything like I just it is I've used
Android I have an s7 I had an s5 I had
something I'd like several phones before
that I'm not anti any of this stuff it's
just I use a samsung phone and it
doesn't feel nice the apps feel clunky
there's all kinds of things just going
on the s7 kept crashing so many times
and it got so hot in my hand that I
actually couldn't even hold it anymore I
basically got the s7 so that I could do
some live streaming a Pokemon go when
I'm playing it but then I decided that
was a really bad idea because live
streaming my exact location while
walking around in strange cities that's
a really bad idea a really bad idea I
had tested it out doing some sort of
unlisted streams just to see what it was
like it was pretty cool but I think my
phone almost exploded although some of
the Samsung phones are exploding you
guys can rage all the wars you want I Oh
s it's it's I mean it's it's just better
also I feel like a lot of people to
always have Android phones so it doesn't
feel awkward to you but then you switch
I I don't know I'm just gonna stop
talking because either way you guys are
gonna get mad at me for saying anything
that I decided to say opinions are not
welcome on the Internet I've found that
out anyway just when the job you guys
pretty quick about the phone my friend
Matt who you may know nadeshot he also
got the jet black version he hasn't put
a case on it it doesn't look too
scratched if you looked at it far away
but if you get up close it's pretty
smudging a little bit scratched but for
the most part I think it held up pretty
well my sister got a red case on her
black phone and it looks so sweet like I
think I need to
a red case I might actually just order
one right now thank you for watching I
will see you in the next video let me
know all of your thoughts about the
iPhone 7 feel free to just rant about
how much you think Android is better or
whatever does whatever I just go for it
really just have at it guys this is
free-range I'll see you in the comments
bye Betty go say hi make me friends
honey I'm NASA set it up recalibrate
because I hadn't recalibrated since New
York so you should definitely calibrate
every tiny block just
[Music]
nothing is untrue